you've been in respectful in under today
I'll be talking with Stefan Heiser the
Archbishop of Hamburg welcome hug
Stephon he said that's if they come
thank you that's if you come up in mind
a warm welcome to you ladies and
gentlemen to the DW interview my name is
Thomas both archbishop the advent period
is a time of great expectations and when
you meet a Catholic Archbishop in person
you would not typically expect a 49 year
old with stubble in a trendy pair of
glasses whom you might see cycling
around the streets of Hamburg was there
surprised among locals over there
noobish hamburger from Illinois and
Bischoff abolished the interest on
tomorrow's daily yes when I cycle past
the Cathedral people come and say you're
a cyclist I thought a special bishops
are still people of course as our
priests 21 days so why shouldn't it
Misha bright a bicycle and Otto Hahn
visual fart found Dolph in the pirogue
in theology there's a nice sentence
about Jesus originating from the church
father several centuries ago in fact
nothing human was alien to him friend
one day I think that's why nothing
should be alien to a bishop of mr.
manages I need to know how people live
and empathize with where they're coming
from so cycling is pretty harmless our
fondest gonzales glenn bobbin let's stay
with nothing human is alien to him your
diocese as it were based at st. George's
in Hamburg is completely removed from
Catholic moral theology you are
surrounded by gay clubs brothels and
street prostitution have you had any
contact saffron voluntary or involuntary
yeah there yes it's not as if we're
living on an island of the Blessed we're
not isolated in a bubble and sometimes I
want to go outside each 142 order and
that means taking in my surroundings
sometimes I do get approached with
offers which is to be expected when you
live around the corner
where prostitutes work open and
depositors you only liked Kwazii on the
acre is I am very much aware of what
goes on in this diocese in this tomb
gift or I can't say whether these people
here are completely removed from our
moral teaching by the San Fernando
Valley and found sent us their people
first and foremost which is why they are
dear to me our mission applies to all
people and in particular to people
living in difficult circumstances what
as I just mentioned the English timish
Milligan said what's your name rafidah
diese i would like to open up the church
so many of these people to homosexuals
and divorces for example who so far have
not been allowed into the church
community is it fair to say the church
has been distinctly unmerciful towards
these people i'm hatsune now yeah I
thought is it a nice or does it's not as
if the church closes its doors to these
groups do you suppose one Golden Fleece
and Rhoda but I'm although unfortunately
some of these people do feel that is the
case open the floor how far and we have
to take this seriously when they're
sitting globish must be our olive so we
have to make it clear to them that they
are welcome and are certainly not locked
out that's who agree on the first of all
out of money it also means talking to
them about their lifestyle you leavin
speiser on and then you have to talk
about certain other things which isn't
bad but you have to do that on a basis
of mutual respect don't for an under
gushy and all people probably have to
fight to get the best out of their lives
and we the church want to help people
where we can then that's my approach at
least dozen songs on thoughts you in for
tomorrow in your own archdiocese of
Hamburg schleswig-holstein mecklenburg
Catholics comprise a tiny minority they
live and work in the diaspora a greek
term meaning being dispersed among those
of different views what can they learn
from these
views equal album that's what I'm vimala
we have to assume that people aren't
simply born into the faith and the
church and gabor as was often the case
in the past but good 15 you're born in
two days later you're baptized today I
often notice people making conscious
decisions as a process of reconciliation
but I'm besitos who you open a mondo
debate over money some make that
decision earlier than others and some
not at all i can do the islands in the
cliff one been beyond skills you die and
if the church in hell con it's doing a
great service in my opinion vampa I'm
grateful for being able to baptize
adults year after year or administer
confirmation to them doesn't many who
are 30 40 or 50 50 of these about this
year we had someone who was almost
eighty who had thought deeply about this
and then made his decision hot that's a
comprehensive answer but the question
was what can we learn from these
different views humility before others
perhaps what demand on the mood was peg
buttons humility or respect can teach us
that the decision to believe is not as
straightforward as we always claimed
that the folks goes your mother's eyes
so I'm and it used to always be a
certainty it's been all but you know I
believe it is a conscious decision or
then something I cannot do for another
person with big I also have to respect
them if they're not readily anything too
wide or if they're no longer ready mr.
white estas con your guns won't of
respect or the old term humility is
always sound advice for Christians
that's caused at all once said in
humility value others above yourselves
we as the church are not supposed to
place ourselves above others that's cool
you got it applies to being a bishop too
I am always supposed to show respect and
benevolence towards others and on the
beginnin this isn't oh you are the
refugee affairs representative of the
German Bishops Conference among the
hundreds of thousands of refugees coming
to Germany are a lot of Muslims joining
those already here
is this a problem for the Catholic
Church because they have a different
belief and as driving throwing the
underflow beans on they may have
different beliefs but it's perhaps
better to call them believers other than
mention these are people from a
monotheistic religion who are often very
convinced of their faith and one death
being so I see entering into a dialogue
with them as a chance common i was in
dialogue finish nua and it's not just
between Christians and Muslims we need
an intercultural dialogue in this
country we have to ask what is it that
holds us together and defines our
society both hilton's I need to them was
Martin Luther draft house I believe that
faith has a role to play and should not
be excluded because he can make life
richer and in a certain sense make it
easier to leave raja mahanakhon hunt in
manchala hands of a fine fahad cut
perhaps compost Francis has declared out
a year of mercy how is the church in
Germany helping refugees speaking as a
meal of a thousand five we have two or
three hundred thousand active Christian
volunteers counting Catholics and
Lutheran's it's vonel and it's we've
provided many apartments and language
courses England and some volunteers
accompany the refugees when they need to
see the authorities on fifth to the boot
common we also provide welcome parties
to greet the refugees see a few of us
it's under common school I'm grateful
for the many things being done but we
have to keep on working on issues such
as integration if people are to stay in
our country which many but not all will
live with other one devote an instead of
living in parallel structures we want
one society in this country and that
will involve a long dialogue and a long
process what's this we're coming off
matzo work through let's now return to
your office here and your neighborhood
one that you could call sexualized you
yourself live the opposite model of life
you chose to renounce sexuality and live
a life of celibacy very bad how
difficult was it to do that
yahan vzm was leaving and mitzvahs
leaving so can as the next mile I'm
scans can also should be accurate there
to do parties celebrate people do not
renounce sexuality just amazing context
they remain sexual beings that's who
most and sexuality is part of being
human middlesex audited um gate although
they have to decide whether they want to
live in celibacy lydon and how to deal
with sexuality and you can't just cut
off sexuality and become ad sexualized
being sexuality is something that always
accompanies people is X what it was from
what I gather from others including
older people it's something that
continues with age imaginal from a total
mention is the trust us that's often
volatile so it's always a part of you
yes nothing is a hottie money and I
believe it is a force of human life the
challenge is everyone the dahcotahs
mention convenes is the Eden her holes
for that that's what that applies to
someone who's married as well as someone
who lives alone whether voluntarily or
involuntarily and there are a lot of
such people each puzzle hidden files I
months was I might try to be a man
minecraft and stay one images in other
sex with young medium and amelie instead
of having a sexual relationship with
somebody I use those forces to be an
emotional and effective beam and
effective as an emotionalless reason so
with everything that entails I don't
want us it's something I find to be very
rich and beautiful it's in no way akin
to a dismemberment or the like those
weight fast after voda at special files
bishop we always conclude our interview
with three incomplete statements for our
guests to finish this year's Christmas
festivities for me mean had ordered for
me it was gun snores something
completely new because it will be my
first Christmas in Hamburg and I wonder
how the new environment might bring me
even closer to the origins of the
festival
thus was willing to dis- Festus have
unlinked I see it as an opportunity to
discover Christmas from a whole new
perspective sue and taken but it's for
the future of the catholic church in
Germany I would like to see wonders me
in a stack of greater joy in the faith
which for me means greater joy and a
closer relationship to Jesus Christ the
faith is based not on believing certain
things but on a personal relationship of
you and I'm hoping for me and others to
intensify that relationship in 2016 that
in this Advent season what do you expect
from the German government's policy
toward the refugees the phone I expected
politicians to show an even clearer
commitment to those people will demand
and introduce unequivocal positions I
anointing and positive there have been
unambiguous statements from our
Chancellor but she needs to close ranks
behind her to please i want to see that
unanimity becoming far clearer feel and
all of it after Bishop Heiser many
thanks for talking to us this way danke
thank you to ashburn